So, the blueprint editor can be quite overwhelming at first. The way I like to think about anything
inside of Unreal Engine is that whatever programs and software you're used to using,
you'll realize that you generally default to the similar set of buttons for 80%
of your usage, you'll get used to the flow and you won't use 100% of the buttons
all the time. So, the first thing to keep in mind is don't let the blueprint
editor interface be too overwhelming, we'll dig into it section by section and you'll find
yourself going to the same bits each time. So, first thing we see is a classic windows
text menu where you'll be able to find a whole bunch of additional functionality that
again you may only use 10% of the time but if you've lost any windows or you need
to file save or you need to edit something, they're the kind of text menus that you'll
find up there. The toolbar is something you'll be using quite a lot of the time, you can
compile your blueprints here, you can save your blueprints, you can browse for other
assets within the blueprint and set up a few different other properties like class
defaults and things like this. The components window is when we're creating a blueprint,
maybe we're creating a player blueprint or maybe we're creating a door blueprint. So,
if we think about the components of a door, maybe we need a door frame, maybe we need
a door, maybe we need a box around the door that says the player is within this box.
These are all components of a blueprint and we would add these to the list. It's
about selecting the components that you need to make your blueprint work. In the instance
of a character for example, you might have the character's mesh, you might have a weapon
that the character is holding, you might have some kind of collision that the player has
surrounding them that they can cause to trigger overlap events. Again, components
are just a selection of these blueprint functionality that you can create your blueprints
with. In section 4 we have the blueprint panel, this is where you'll be adding variables
and bits of code and you'll be able to see the graph from a higher level about the
kind of inputs that you have here and any kind of main functions. So, think of the blueprint
panel as where most of the data is housed. Now, if we then go into number 5, this is
where all our gameplay scripting actually takes place. You'll see that you can toggle
to the viewport in the top left of section 5 here and the viewport will show you in
a visual representation the components that you have in your blueprint. So again, referencing
section 3 of the list of your components, then in section 5 at the top left the viewport
will help you visualise these components. So if you did select a door with a doorframe,
you'd be able to see these elements in that viewport. The construction script is something
we'll get into in a few minutes again. It's a slightly more complex concept but essentially
the construction script will fire every time you compile. So again, those familiar
with C++ will be more familiar with the construction script but even if you're not familiar with
C++, don't worry, we'll dig into that again. And the event graph is where you'll
be spending the majority of your time. It houses all the gameplay code that you need
for this specific blueprint 2 function. Don't worry too much about the print text next
to the event graph. The print text is a function that we have inside of this blueprint. You
can open the function and edit it and that's more like a quick bar to get to that. So
if I close print text that wouldn't be an issue. We only want to be editing quick
context there and the viewport, the construction script and the event graph are the main
things to worry about there. And then in section 6 we have the details of whatever
we currently have selected. So in this example we've got a variable selected which is a
bool and we can edit some of the default properties of this bool. And so you'll be
using the details panel quite a lot in your blueprint journey and it allows you to add
the functionality and customization to the blueprints that you are creating.